how you guys doing welcome welcome to
the channel if you're new to the channel
subscribe right now hit that
notification bell
so you don't miss out when we put out
an exciting video an informative video
an educational video or weekly show that
comes out
alhamdulillah so
a friend of mine shared with me a
very interesting article
which is titled
muslims among
most generous
in overall u.s population the study says
so i want to share this with you i
thought it was very very intriguing
and it starts off
like this muslims in the united states
gave an estimated 4.3 billion
billion dollars to charity in
2020
making them one of the most generous
religious groups in the u.s a new study
has found so let's go ahead and skim
through this article where it talks
about muslims in the united states gave
an estimated 4.3 billion to charity in
2020 making them one of the most
generous religious groups in the u.s a
new study is found
you can go ahead and look this study up
and you can look up this
article
by dan parks
says we have always known that american
muslims are exceedingly generous and
philanthropic charity is a central
pillar in the islamic faith and deeply
entrenched into our way of life another
quote here muslim americans are stepping
up to play an important role in making
our world a nation better despite facing
prejudice
greater scrutiny and having fewer
resources said
sharik sadiqi assistant professor all
right so this is a very interesting
article here i wanted to share with you
guys
because
it's contrary to usually what the
average person gets to see of islam and
muslims
on the
daily media machine
so
i think that this would be a great
a great piece
for
some of the local stations and even some
of the bigger stations worldwide to pick
up
this story this is huge so and then link
the two how can people
what's motivating muslims to be so
generous
what's it about their faith what is it
about islam because that's the driving
force islam because of others we'll have
you believe that islam is a driving
force to violence to terrorism
i mean total hogwash and nonsense that
just stinks it really stinks
and for anybody who's intelligent i mean
it's it's just amazing many academics
many people like jordan peterson
uh and others who've fallen for this and
they've said some as have been pointed
out by many muslims they've they've made
some really
some blunders huge blunder these are
academics people are supposed to be
reading enlightened smart but they also
they get affected
by the hate machine by the negative by
the false propagandists out there
so what's the driving force to motivate
these muslims out there and again muslim
what's a muslim muslim is one who
submits his or her will to the creator
of the heavens and earth the same way
jesus did moses abraham the last and
final ministry of prophet muhammad peace
be upon him all that's what a muslim is
the one who follows islam islam is
calling the human being to know his
creator to know why you've been created
what's the purpose of life and then
to follow it to submit not to your
desires not to a human being not to
money fame power but to submit to the
creator of the human being the creator
of the universe and everything in it the
one and only god almighty allah this is
the creator the one that jesus worships
so this is what islam is what a muslim
is and what's driving muslims to do that
to be the most terrible
charitable
is this deep devotion this consciousness
of their creator and the afterlife
knowing that this life is short so a
muslim
is preparing because the quran is the
verbatim word of god almighty and has a
deep description has a detailed
description of the afterlife
so one of the ways to achieve
greater ranks
to
get more rewards more of the mercy
from god almighty the creator allah is
giving in charity this is a way to keep
one away from the hellfire and it has to
be based on that pure monotheism of
course and then implementing the five
pillars of islam and then giving back
being altruistic giving back to humanity
giving back to
the poor the poor have rights over us
and islam
is that driving force that's helping
that's motivating muslims to be the most
generous so get to know islam get to
know your muslims visit a mosque and
hopefully share this share this with uh
email this story to some of the local
stations the news outlets cnn fox news
all these and and
and advise them encourage them to share
stories like this
it's a long shot
but uh
why not and tune in here every week at
the d show we'll see you next time peace
be with you assalamu alaikum